Fox News Alert hundreds are reportedly
dead after an explosion at a hospital in
Gaza Israel pushing back after Hamas
claimed the Carnage was caused by an
Israeli air strike brand new vide
showing the chaotic scene outside the
hospital where up to 500 people are
feared dead Israeli Prime Minister
Netanyahu is reacting and saying quote
the entire world should know it was
barbaric terrorists and Gaza that
attacked the hospital in Gaza and not
the IDF those who brutally murdered our
children also murder their own children
Mike Tobin is in southern Israel with
the latest on that developing situation
Mike and judge essentially what we're
hearing from the IDF it was Palestinian
Islamic Jihad that launched a barrage of
rockets that was going to go over the
hospital there one of those rockets at
least one of them was errant struck in
the vicinity of the hospital causing the
explosion and hundreds of Civilian
casualties again that is from the IDF
and here is an explanation or at least a
version uh from an adviser to to uh
prime minister Benjamin
Netanyahu Israel does not Target places
like hospitals they're not a target for
us and we wouldn't have deliberately hit
a hospital number two uh we know that at
the time of the of this tragedy that
Kamas was firing a barrage of rockets at
Tel Aviv up to third of rockets fired
from Gaza fall inside the Gaza Strip
because they malfunction it is possible
that this was one of those rockets that
malfunctioned now the Arab world was
quick to blame the Israelis in fact in
the Gaza Strip the Palestinian Health
Ministry run by Hamas said it was an
Israeli air strike we've seen
demonstrations uh form up in the West
Bank in am man Jordan Palestinian
president Mahmud Abbas dropped out of
his planned meeting with President Biden
for tomorrow in protest test over this
explosion of the hospital judge have you
heard anything uh Mike about the
misfires I mean previous misfires before
today there have been multiple misfires
keep in mind these Rockets a lot of them
are just made in machine shops in the
Gaza Strip uh they have misfired in the
past they've hit uh um civilians there's
one case where an infant was killed by
one of these errant rockets in the past
and uh the Palestinians have always been
quick to blame Israel it takes a while
for the facts to come out as it did in
this case from the Israeli side all
right all right we'll go around the
table Harold Mike thank you for all your
great reporting you've been fantastic
along with the entire team there has
there been any um comment from uh the
Biden Administration I know that the
meeting has been cancelled uh but has
the president or blink anybody responded
number one on that front and two um have
there been any of the reaction from
other Arab leaders about meeting with
President Biden on this upcoming
trip well you've heard a lot of protests
and a lot of anger come from the uh
surrounding Arab states and that will
always happen whenever it looks like
Israel is at fault you're get a lot of
anger galvanizing and unifying the uh
the surrounding Arab states and that
indeed is happening uh all the way to
Turkey as far as what's happening in
Washington I'm I'm really buried in this
stuff right now congressman and I I
don't know what's happening in DC keep
up the great work and be safe Jesse does
the IDF Mike have any technology that
they can show to the world that proves
in terms of surveillance that this
missile did not come from Israel then in
fact it actually was a missile from
Terris in
Gaza well the drones are up I can hear
the drones right now they're always
surveying the uh the the Gaza Strip and
the and the area of combat uh Israel has
air superiority they don't have any
reason to take the drones down uh other
than weather uh there's also there's an
Al jazer broadcast that's going around
on the internet right now I can't verify
it but they claim at least uh through
social media that it shows the moment of
impact the moment the uh Islamic Jihad
rocket went air and hit the hospital but
uh not verified Jesse all right Dana
Mike you said something important that
the Gaza Health Ministry is run by Hamas
and Hamas runs the hospital and Hamas
hides their weapons inside the hospital
I'm curious It's a little bit along the
lines of what Jesse just said which is
when something like this happens and
there's an immediate reaction in fact
some major media organizations
immediately said that this was Israel's
fault but how do you go about on the
ground there as a reporter to try to get
to the truth what is the best way if we
know that Hamas runs the health Ministry
and runs the
hospital well Gaza is very difficult
right now it's it's difficult to
communicate with Gaza and the year
contacts have all fled South uh some of
them don't have their phones working so
any information out of Gaza is difficult
if you get it through the uh through the
Hamas sources know that they are playing
the pr game it's a very important
component uh of their strategy so you
have to doubt everything uh everything
you receive uh the Israelis were a
little slower to respond because they
wanted to do some analysis of the facts
first uh so it took a little while to
get the version from Israel where the
Arab reaction was immediate and in fact
it spread all around the Arab world uh
while the Israelis took a moment to do
some analysis uh we'll see if we get
more data going forward from the
Israelis more evidence more proof going
forward but right now the IDF says it
was indeed an errant um uh rocket from
Palestinian Islamic Jihad not
Hamas hey Mike it's Greg uh we know
hamas's strategy is to maximize civilian
deaths even their own sometimes
especially their own to Galvanize the
globe against Israel Israel's strategy
is opposite of that they don't try to
hit any civilians and yet after every
one of these things there always seems
to be the outrage always builds towards
Israel no matter what happens especially
in the western media do do you know
why well that goes back a long time
frankly it goes back to uh the event
that the Palestinians call the nakba uh
when uh when the state of Israel was
formed and the Palestinians claimed they
will run off their land so there was
always been Unity there's always been
anger against Israel and you uh and you
always see the uh not only the the Arab
states but the media uh will generally
be quick to uh uh reach a conclusion
against Israel and then you have the
overwhelming fact that Israel was
conducting unprecedented air strikes
into the Gaza Strip something blows up
and it's it's not a surprise that the
first conclusion that people would jump
to would be that it was Israel but you
also have deadly Rockets being fired out
by the Palestinians all the time and uh
they're not good quality
weapons okay Mike thanks so much and uh
we'll take it around the table for a few
minutes you know Jesse There is video
floating around you would ask the
question about whether or not there was
any way to identify but there's video
floating around that has not yet been um
uh certified or confirmed proving that
it's Palestinian they say you see a
massive barrage fired at Israel on the
right and a few seconds later there's an
explosion on the left in a direction
opposite where the all the other
missiles are going so it may be as
simple as a video that can show what
what's happened here and Israel should
be very Vigilant in exploiting their
technology and surveillance capabilities
is to win this war in the Press because
the Press has a lot of effect upon what
the Israeli military is going to be able
to do because you know they're going to
be under so much pressure to go in on
the ground and go in quickly when it's
not an easy job when you deal with
tunnels uh th this strike obviously
complicates the Biden visit uh he did
not expect this to happen now he's going
down a day later after 200 civilians are
allegedly dead and and there's an
information Warfare situation that he
needs to get out there and say if I were
the president I would be very clear that
you cannot believe what you hear from
the Palestinians you cannot believe what
you hear from Hamas they are
traditionally uh deceptive and they're
even denying some of the things that
they did to these children and to these
women
so if I were Israel I would just be
flooding the zone with as many facts and
and as many exhibits to prove that what
they're doing is righteous and what
they're doing is surgical because this
is this is tough this is really no one
likes to see people die in a hospital
like that yeah and you know Dana I mean
given that they're historically known
for uh putting themselves and putting
situations uh where they're going to be
targeted near a hospital this is kind of
consistent with their game plan it is
one thing I was thinking about that's
different though in from years past is
the technology that civilians have or
even that the terrorists had right so
the terrorists had their phones and
their GoPro cameras cuz they wanted us
to see the terror that they were
creating and a situation like this even
a few years ago would have taken maybe
days to figure out was it an errant
rocket here we are just mere hours later
with different video and different set
of facts and a a different angles of the
video so that Israel which has a PR war
that it needs to wage as well in order
to protect itself from Attack that it is
the one who causes civilian harm or
humanitarian crisis there's actually
some real benefit to having this
immediate Viewpoint it's a strange way
to do Warfare right now so now Hamas has
decided that Innocents are the ones who
can be targeted but now we also have the
video evidence that we can use
immediately to see as journalists that's
why I asked Mike like how on the ground
are they figuring that out it's very
chaotic there but within hours we were
able to figure this out yep
Greg uh I'm surprised that Hamas did I I
would assume that they would deny
hitting a hospital because that's where
they keep their command centers that
would have been my excuse uh um but I
think the pr war is pointless because
this has been going on forever and the
media continues just to jump to the same
conclusions and you even I mean
everybody knows what Hamas does their
their whole point is to maximize
civilian casualties to create Global
disgust about the Jews no matter what
the Jews do that's what's going to
happen I think that at this point you
just try to win and the pr stuff that's
secondary I think it's secondary but
it's definitely a component when you're
dealing with a lot of disingenuous
people in the press and and Harold isn't
it isn't it important to do this now if
they're worried about is the IDF gone in
for them President Biden in his words a
few days ago urged uh encouraged his
Israelis to respond with Force to defend
their country and to to follow the law
what I saw from the Israelis this
afternoon was what you would want to see
from a democracy what you expect to see
they refrain from speaking too quickly
they investigated they got the facts and
laid out and we likely will get video
the video that we've seen and others may
have seen U we've not showed it I think
yet but we may see this video later in
the evening proving that this was not an
Israeli strike the Israelis don't do
this as the as the senior adviser to Mr
nyaho is repeat it furthermore this
incident it's tragic uh and we should
all acknowledge the tragedy of it and
two it will further isolate Hamas and
further isolate Iran I agree with some
many around the table The Narrative
around the media and where the some in
the media have gone but this the fact
that the the Hamas immediate reaction
has always been to blame the Israelis
but we're it's now a it's on a global
media stage for everyone to see what's
happening it's tragic what is happening
and what has happened but the Israelis
didn't do it and isolating Iran and
isolating Hamas has to be at the
Forefront of what we try to get done
here all right hi everyone I'm Brian
kilme I want you to do me a favor I want
you to click to subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube page this is the only way
that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now